[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON SCOTT: Hi, everyone.
Welcome back to the Dev Zone.
So my name is Jason
Scott, and I'm
excited to bring to you,
the next presentation
around leveraging cloud
data and ML for social good.
I currently am a global program
manager for our startup program
here at Google Cloud.
And I have two
special guests, that
are going to talk
about how they're
leveraging Google Cloud
for social impact for work.
But first, I'd like to rewind
about 12 months-- actually,
10 months--
to when Sundar announced
our AI principles.
For those of you who
may not remember,
I'll quickly go
over what they were.
So our first six principles
were be socially beneficial.
Avoid creating or
reinforcing unfair bias.
Be built and tested for safety.
Be accountable to people.
Incorporate privacy
design principles.
And six, uphold high standards
of scientific excellence.
However, today, I'd like
to focus on number seven.
So number seven was
be made available
for uses that accord
with these principles.
So today, I'm going to bring up
two of our example startups--
companies-- that will talk about
how they've leverage Google
Cloud to-- like I said-- make
social impactful solutions
for the world.
First up, I have Planet.
GOPAL ERINJIPPURATH:
Hello, everyone.
It's been great hearing all
the tremendous announcements
around AI and new
tech in Google Cloud
Platform over the course
of the last couple of days
and this week, at Next.
And I'm excited
to be telling you
a little bit about
what Planet is doing
in the context of social good.
So I'm Gopal.
I head up analytics
engineering at Planet.
Planet's an integrated
aerospace and data analytics
company, founded
with the mission
of imaging the entire
world every day
and making daily change visible,
accessible, and actionable.
Planet operates the
largest constellation
of Earth observation
satellites in human history.
And here's a quick run through
of how our satellites operate.
We have upwards of 130
satellites operating
in a sun-synchronous polar
orbit that image the Earth like
a line scanner.
Our flagship Dove constellation
allows for broad area
always on monitoring.
And we complement that
with a medium resolution
constellation, called the
SkySat constellation, that
allows for higher
resolution monitoring.
In broad area monitoring,
you're able to cover
large swaths of land
and be able to have
precise insights
derived from imagery
over the course of time.
So a little bit more about
the Dove constellations.
We image at
approximately 3.9 meters
ground sampling distance.
We have full bands of imagery.
And through the launches
over the last several years,
we now cover the entirety of
the Earth's landmass every day.
This allows for us
to be able to image,
and process, and serve
imagery to our customers.
So we have product offerings
through our API that
allow for access to raw
and processed scenes,
as well as a collection of
monthly and seasonal mosaics
that are available
to our customers.
The availability of our
imagery has enabled customers
in many different
verticals to provide
transformative new capabilities
that can serve verticals,
like, precision agriculture,
government applications.
And we believe that our
forward looking vision
is at the intersection of space
and artificial intelligence--
very relevant to
this conference.
So over the last several
years, our customers
have been able to extract
a variety of features
from our imagery.
This includes moving objects
through object detection, land
use classification through
semantic segmentation,
and land cover mapping using a
combination of texture analysis
and semantic segmentation.
However, those are a
few of the applications
that are commercially-oriented.
The imagery that we produce from
our satellite constellations
have the potential for
widespread humanitarian impact.
Disasters-- natural
disasters impact
large swaths of population.
They have the ability
to affect broad aspects
of our social fabric over
a very quick time period.
I wanted to walk through
an example of cyclone area
assessment.
So many of you know
about cyclone Idai,
that impacted the east
coast of Africa in March.
And it had tremendous
impact over large areas
in the country of Mozambique.
And here's just an
example of the regions
which it did affect.
Zooming in a little
bit more closely--
this is an area in the
Dondo district in Mozambique
that had widespread devastation.
So looking at monthly
mosaics in this area,
this is what it looks
like in January.
Now, the impact of having
daily imagery and monitoring
[INAUDIBLE] satellite
Earth observation is
that you are able to extract
real-time information
or close to real-time
information of the disaster
affected areas.
Not just before, but also look
at the catalog and history
of what the area looked like.
It allows you to identify
spots, like this,
with tremendous amount of human
activity and human settlement.
This allows disaster
relief efforts
to be equipped
with high precision
maps of human activity.
And it helps channel
relief efforts
in the right direction
in specific locations.
However, public
mapping information
is often incomplete.
So in that particular
tile of mosaic imagery,
this is the existing mockup of
roads from a public data set
like OpenStreetMap.
However, when we run
semantic segmentation
on our imagery from a month
before the cyclone hit,
you are able to see a
lot more roads detected.
This is a differential signal
of the additional roads that are
detected through our imagery.
And it allows for us to
combine these two sources--
public, as well as data
derived from Planet's imagery--
towards creating signals
that can help responders
at the time of need.
So I wanted to walk
through a slightly more
interactive example.
So this is the imagery
in that particular region
of Mozambique.
And here's an example
of road detections.
What you see in red are
pixels classified as roads
through semantic segmentation.
We can also identify other
artifacts of human settlement,
like buildings.
So this is an indicator
of building footprints
in that region.
And you could serve
this up at a larger
scale over multiple districts.
And this is
real-time information
that can be used in
disaster activities.
Switching back-- I want
to talk a little bit
about ocean monitoring.
So typhoons and tsunamis
often originate in the oceans.
And they have widespread
impact on land regions,
as well as marine life.
However, monitoring
oceans over a large scale
is relatively
complex of a problem.
And has been less
addressed in the past.
So I want to walk through
an example of that.
Before we look at oceans, I
wanted to first look at ports.
Here's an imagery of the
Port of Oakland taken
from our satellites yesterday.
And when we run an
object detector,
you're able to clearly
identify port activity,
like ships and
boats, that provide
a real-time signal on the
kind of aggregate activity
in the region.
So switching into a more
interactive exploration--
so this is that same
region over Oakland
for an aggregate activity
over the entire year.
So we looked at object
detection over the entire--
everyday over the
course of this year.
And loaded up the detections
and Kepler.gl, an open source
package.
And you can see
real-time activity
over the port over
the course of time.
Each of these have
endured over a couple
of days, which showcase
the kind of activity,
allowing for real-time
environmental monitoring.
In the same way, if you
pointed to open ocean--
here's an example.
This is in the South China Sea,
closer to the Indian Ocean,
which is the origin
of many, many tsunamis
over the last several years.
It allows you to understand
real-time patterns of life,
as well as activity
in the marine regions
that allow for
preemptively signaling
in the time of disasters.
To switch over to a different
region, which impacts all of us
in terms of sea routes for
distribution of material
and goods, is the Panama Canal.
So if you zoom in closer,
we're able to detect
through our imagery, over the
course of two years, the kind
of activity that you can see.
This allows the kind
of real-time monitoring
that is unprecedented, primarily
because of the limited coverage
in open ocean, as
well as marine areas.
So in summary,
through a combination
of such real-time environmental
sensing, as well as broad area
monitoring, we're able to
extract information that
was previously less available.
This allows us to serve
transformative applications
in many different
vertical industries
but also serve that same
information for social good--
for monitoring
disasters, identifying
environmental impact,
and understanding what's
really happening on the
ground at a larger scale.
Most importantly, it allows
us to turn our attention
to problems where
real-time sensing
and real-time
environmental monitoring
can provide real value.
This takes us from the realm
of Earth observation imagery
to derived data.
And from derived data
to descriptive analytics
and spatiotemporal
insights that allow
us to understand what's
happening in the world.
So here are a few resources,
if you find this interesting.
And myself and a couple
of colleagues are here.
After this session, we
would love to talk more,
if you're interested in
insights from satellite imagery.
And big thanks to Google
for having us here.
We use a significant amount of
Google-- the storage, compute,
and orchestration capabilities
that Google Cloud offers.
We're serving up
over 7 terabytes
of processed imagery every day.
So with that, thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
JASON SCOTT: Thank you, Gopal.
And lastly-- in the
interest of time--
I'll bring right up
our next startup--
Mayday.ai.
They can talk about--
in the theme of
natural disasters--
how they're leveraging
Google Cloud,
specifically AutoML,
to save a lot of lives.
JACOB STABLER: Thank you.
So Mayday is an artificial
intelligence-based platform.
And we do natural disaster
information services.
So since the '80s, we have
had $1.6 trillion damages.
One of the most
costliest years recently
was 2017, when it came
to flooding, storms,
and wildfires, and
even the red tide.
2019 had one of the
wettest winters on record.
Some of the biggest
natural disasters
that cause economic losses are
storms, wildfires, and floods.
About 70% of the US is at
risk from natural disasters.
We've shifted from being
seasonable and predictable to
being random and unpredictable.
The frequency and severity
of these storms and disasters
have made management
even more challenging.
So a lot of the
problems that we come
into with disaster management
is outdated platforms.
They are decentralized.
They don't communicate
with each other.
There is also a lack of
education and training
when it comes to these.
So with Mayday, we have
solved some of these problems.
We've created a centralized
artificial intelligence
platform that is cloud-based.
We have microservices that
track real-time and near
real-time disaster
information services.
From those events, we
have localized and group
messaging based to individuals.
We have a simple and
user-friendly design, also.
We are highly affordable.
We are free to students.
We have $1.99 for families
and $0.99 for individuals.
All right, I'd like to go ahead
and hand it over to Nitin,
our CEO.
NITIN KUMAR: Thank you, Jacob.
This is Mayday.ai
ecosystem looks like.
We cater to residential,
commercial, and government
enterprise.
Our applications
runs on web, iOS,
and Android mobile devices.
The core part of our platform
is microservices and AI--
microservices being excellent
to integrate and deliver
disaster information services
and AI is our brainchild.
With AI, we can
automate a lot of things
which humans are doing.
We can detect these
disasters through data
in real-time and 24 by 7
and get a quick insight.
Our data sources-- we integrate
with various data sources.
NOAA-- we're a part of
NOAA's Big Data program.
Using historical
data, we train our AI
based on the previous
events which have happened.
We also have real-time access
to geostationary satellites.
We get data feeds
every 30 seconds
for the entire continental US.
We use our own
proprietary algorithms
to detect fire hotspot
and other disasters.
To augment our capabilities,
we rely on visual inspections
as well--
drone being one of them.
Drones can go to the areas
where human reach is not
easily accessible.
They can go and do a
reconnaissance operation
and give us real-time
video feeds,
which we can pass
it through our AI
and detect actionable events.
We're also planning to use
drones for disaster management
and control.
When the fire is small,
it's easy to tackle.
And that's where
we want to offer--
drones can go out and
put out the fire when
it's small and containable.
We also want to integrate
various sensors and equipments,
which has been installed
by various climatologists
and scientific organizations.
Social media, sentiment
analysis, and another piece
of our offering--
people who are in
the disaster areas,
they get the
information firsthand.
They tweet about it.
They post videos, images.
And using that social
media integration,
we want to analyze,
and bring awareness,
and training of those disasters.
These are some of the
man-made and natural disasters
which we cater to our platform.
We also want to
integrate to IP 911
to bring active
shooter and terrorism
activities in real-time.
This is a brief video
which demonstrates
the capability of our platform.
Back in 2018, we detected
Camp and Woolsey fires
within minutes of it happening.
As you can see in this
video, we have annotations--
these yellow boxes being
potential fire hotspot,
green ones could be
false or non-event,
and the red are active hotspot.
We can also see
smoke, and cloud,
and other geological
phenomenas which
helps fire first responders
understand the situation.
AI being a big part
of our offering,
this is a demonstration
of AutoML Vision.
This is the first part
of visual detection.
We use satellite
imagery and we're
handling this model using--
this is a short example,
being smoke cloud and clear.
Using AutoML Vision,
we train the model.
And after training, it's
available as an end point.
Using this end point,
we integrated real-time
with our live feeds of images.
And this is a short example of
how we can detect smoke cloud
with very high accuracy.
Another part of our visual
offering is AutoML Video.
We work with Google
in a beta program
where we use our drone
footage and train
it to detect smoke, fire, and
other objects in the scene.
Imagine a drone going to place
and give us a real-time video.
And we pass it through
the streaming API
and generate actionable event.
Using this-- this is the
third part of our AI strategy.
With this, I'll hand
it over to Jacob
to talk about our roadmap.
JACOB STABLER: So
in May, we are going
to launch in eight cities in
Orange County, California.
From there, we are going to
create disaster awareness
campaigns for educational
institutes and high occupancy
buildings.
We will also be launching
later in the year in all
of US and Canada with
the IP 911 integration.
I just wanted to say thanks
to Jason and the rest
of the Google team.
NITIN KUMAR: And I
also want to thank
Google technical team,
who I have worked closely
during the beta program.
They have been really helpful.
And thank you.
JACOB STABLER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]